my name is MIA Vashi coughs gun I'm
Robert Pattinson we're doing the wired
or a complete interview this is like
being in school write music which why
yes they did did you yeah dude rope
Edison thing let me think
yeah I think I'm playing the guitar and
singing without producing Twilight yeah
it's when Bella is having the poison
taken out some might say the climax of
the movie did Robert Pattinson have a
baby
Wow did you I don't think you can have a
baby how to pronounce me just let it
roll she called Scott 28
yeah how what did you think I was how
tall is me magic about 176 centimeters
which is maybe 5 moreish no 5 4 I think
so
does that sound right not if I fall I
think I'm 5'4 how did me of ashitaka
become famous
did she I don't think she did I don't
know how old is Mae Fah Tchaikovsky in
Alice and wonderland I think I was 18 19
what is Robert Pattinson's full name
Patrick no no no yes well you know that
well I have a friend called Patrick
Douglas what is Robert Pattinson's first
maybe Vanity Fair
maybe even I know that wasn't your fence
maybe it was was it I was cut out their
accent it's a mixture insecurities like
not trying to disguise the fact that
none of the words coming out mean
anything do you think a lot without like
saying anything
okay what is what Robert Pattinson
character Oh Cedric degree yep what is
Robert Pattinson's zodiac sign I'm gonna
guess is it like Gemini a lot of people
in Amgen right there's your triple
Taurus triple Taurus what does that mean
my rising and my pulling of course who
does me look like I did have someone
being like you look just like the girl
from Alice in Wonderland I think her
name is Claire Danes but either way it's
a compliment I was like thanks Gazoo
blings Danone is the oldest and then
jess and then me and then my brother kai
25 it's me ever should call Scott
related to Gwyneth Paltrow I don't know
not that no not that I know of English
my mom's polish yep he's Robert
Patterson nice yes very nice is Robert
Patterson ginger a little bit a little
bit is Robert Pattinson vegetarian no no
who is Robert Pattinson best friend
strengthening Sam Marcus Tom and Jamie
know how am i blanking I literally saw
him this morning Bobby wife we just did
two wired order complete interview
I have enough hay